hey guys Ryan Wright here and today I'm
gonna be watching the trailer for edge
of tomorrow sorry one of my favorite
actors Thomas Cruise now a lot of people
don't like Tom Cruise because he's a
Scientologist and because he fell in
love with Katie Holmes two reasons that
I really don't give a [ __ ] about he can
believe whatever he wants to believe and
he can bang wherever he wants to bang
anyway I think Tom Cruise is one of the
best most intense actors we have I saw
the first trailer for edge of tomorrow
thought it looked awesome it looks a lot
like Tom Cruise his other movies but
still looks pretty [ __ ] cool I mean
he's made a great comeback with just
doing a bunch of action films I think
this film is gonna rock it's from
director Doug Liman but he's done some
good movies too Bourne Identity mr. and
mrs. Smith and jumper there we go time
to watch Tom Cruise do his perfect
posture run is already so intense
there's a lot like oblivion here how
many times for me it's been an eternity
whoa [ __ ] oh damn this loose [ __ ]
awesome
below the production design cool music
I die within five minutes I ever get
sweet that looks
nice come find me when you wake up Oh No
he's always riding motorcycles too
what happened to you happened to me dad
I'm really ones gonna kick ass you have
to die every day keep coming here and
I'll training
your legs broken no I'm good can you get
it started
soldier
your listen
lived I remove all
you change their nose [ __ ]
every penny what are you not telling me
there's a lot she's not telling me IMAX
I saw that dude that film looks [ __ ]
sweet that is one of my most anticipated
movies of 2014 without a doubt I love a
good science-fiction picture and that
looks [ __ ] sweet it looks tight it
looks badass
it looks just [ __ ] epic production
design looks great visuals look awesome
and I love hot ass [ __ ] you can kick
ass like Emily boring I like the idea
that Tom Cruise is kind of this rookie
in a way who's mean trained by any he
just come in put a [ __ ] lucky bastard
every time he dies you just got to come
back I don't get this gonna have a
climactic ending if Tom Cruise and just
come back every time I don't know if I'm
really gonna feel like he's in danger or
not but regardless it looks really cool
and the concept is awesome and I know
it's based off a comic book called all
you need is kill I personally prefer
that title that just sounds a lot more
badass so yeah that film looks [ __ ]
sweet and if you're new to the channel
subscribe subscribe tell me more
trailers to watch I always get the best
announcements from you guys because I
get like 50 comments telling me watch
this new trailer and then when I heard
this trailer was out I was psyched to
watch it because I really do love Tom
Cruise I think Tom Cruise is just
[ __ ] awesome he's so intense and the
last trailer for edge of tomorrow looks
like it was a kind of a ripoff of a
bunch of Tom Cruise movies but this one
looks more unique kosha could have a
do-over from every time I've had bad sex
with someone or if I had great sex and I
could just repeat that and repeat that
over and over probably get bored the
chick though